vous avez rappelé tout à l'heure que là
ça fait un Guyane a eu beaucoup de mal
pour s'installer ça fait déjà plus de
deux ans d'ailleurs et pourtant cette
structure n'est toujours pas
opérationnelle faute d'agrément c'est
agrément devait être délivré par votre
ministère depuis plusieurs mois outre le
fonctionnement l'absence d'agrément
entrave l'accès aux subventions
publiques et ne permet pas à la faire de
garantir son budget alors première
question monsieur le ministre quand la
SAFER Guyane obtiendra-t-elle son
agrément la deuxième question concerne
le droit de préhension justement qui
permet de imiter la spéculation foncière
et favoriser le développement local
aussi Monsieur le Ministre pouvons-nous
imaginer une adaptation du droit de
préhension de la sincère de Guyane car
je rappelle qu'en Guyane il y a une
prédominance de beau en phytéotique qui
permet souvent à des particuliers de
réaliser des projets privés en ayant
échappé à l'exercice du droit de
préhension et pour terminer vous l'avez
évoqué tout à l'heure lors des Accords
de Guyane signé le 21 avril 2017 la
collectivité de Guyane et l'État c'était
engagée à fournir les moyens financiers
pour le démarrage de la SAFER Liam soit
500000 euros annuel pouvez-vous me dire
quand le ministère de l'Agriculture
respectera son engagement
je prends en cours de route ce sujet qui
m'a l'air un peu compliqué
premier élément fallait qu'on trouve une
solution de gouvernance avec la
désignation d'une nouvelle présidente
qui puisse agréer si je peux dire
localement dans des conditions que je ne
vous décris pas parce que vous
connaissez comme moi la situation de
danse tension
j'ai été sollicité par la safarnationale
d'ailleurs il va être procédé à
l'agrément de la présidente dans la
semaine donc première élément agréer la
présidente deuxième élément elle a
vocation une fois qu'elle est agrée
parce que c'est un peu chat qui se mord
la queue il a précédé il peut pas y
avoir de plans puret annuel comme
beboper plus réel et pas les moyens qui
sont dévolués donc deuxième élément dès
lors qu'elle va être agréée il lui
appartiendra et nous on est prêt à
accompagner et à les aider dans cette
affaire là
c'est ce que c'est ce que j'allais
presque vous dire mais mettez les mots
de la bouche on peut essayer de regarder
pour avoir parce qu'il y a eu du temps
perdu je ne dis pas le contraire là faut
qu'on fasse ça mais il faut qu'on a un
plan plus réel qui permettra par
ailleurs et ensuite de faire en sorte
que le plan pluriel le programme pure
annuel d'activité puisse permettre
d'agréer assez vite parce que je suis
d'accord avec vous ça a assez duré de
regarder comment
comment ça peut se faire d'un point de
vue financier vous l'avez dit Madame
sénatrice c'est la troisième étape parce
qu'il y a des besoins d'activer les
sujets de droit de pension donc c'est
dans cet ordre là que c'est fait je suis
à votre disposition continue ainsi que
mon cabinet
ici présent pour pour que vous me disiez
si ça bloque si vous avez besoin de
soutien complémentaire on est tout à
fait à votre disposition parce que je
sais que c'est un outil dont vous avez
besoin juste un mot il y avait des
reliquats ou des éléments de financement
dans le gif de la précédente safer qui
vont être versées à la SAFER
nouvellement en cours d'agrément mais
c'est pas les c'est pas les sommes
encore en jeu mais ça participera de la
de l'équation financière qu'il faut
qu'on essaie de trouver